welcome back to New rockstars I'm Mary
boss and this is a breakdown of the new
trailer for Star Wars Ahsoka coming to
Disney Plus on August 23rd with a two
episode premiere with Rosario Dawson as
the X Jedi originally from clone wars
and Rebels animated series now in live
action from the Mandalorian and its
spin-offs whether that sounds like a lot
of homework to you or if you want
everyone to love look ATS as much as you
do I got you covered with a frame by
frame breakdown of this trailer and what
to know headed into this series a
reminder that new rockstars is now three
channels this main channel for Easter
egg breakdowns the Deep dive for special
film analyzes and the break room where
you will find our Ahsoka after show
Wikileaks from here on out subscribe to
all three of these channels that support
our network with the shirt from
nerdriot.shop let's get started
whoa this is inevitable
one Must Destroy
in order to create
we are no Jedi
before we get into this a quick recap
ahsokitano is the former Jedi Apprentice
to Anakin Skywalker introduced in Clone
Wars when she was then voiced by Ashley
Eckstein Ahsoka left the Jedi Order
after being framed for a bombing of the
Jedi Temple she returned later in the
Star Wars timeline during the events of
the rebels and briefly teamed up with
the crew of the ghost which included the
pilot Harrison Doula the Mandalorian
ex-imperial weapons expert Sabine Wren
fugitive Jedi Kanan Jairus his
Apprentice Ezra Bridger Zeb and the
Astromech droid Chopper the end of the
series Ezra vanished along with the
villain Grand Admiral thrawn due to some
Pergo hyperspace whales and the series
ends with ahsoken Sabine teaming up to
look for Ezra now Ahsoka showed up in
live action in season 2 of the
Mandalorian now played by Rosario Dawson
dueling Morgan L Smith and seeking Grand
admiralth Ron asok also showed up again
in the book of Boba Fett chatting with
Luke Skywalker when he trained grogu
this show is essentially a live action
season of rebels Mary Elizabeth Winstead
is now playing Harrison Doula Natasha
Leo bordizo is Sabine Wren Iman espandez
Ezra Bridger Mars Mickelson returns as
Grand Admiral thrawn after voicing the
hair character in Rebels Steve Bloom
returned as the live-action Zeb in the
Mandalorian last season presumably he's
going to be in the show too and Chopper
likely played by the same Droid demon as
before because he's a total monster this
trailer opens with an ETA Class Shuttle
approaching a new Republic Cruiser this
type of ADA Class Shuttle was used in
the Clone Wars by Jedi ambassadors
telling us that its occupants Balin and
shin are using it deceptively and the
framing here makes it look like this Ada
Class Shuttle is pincering the new
Republic craft that's about to board
bayland's skull is a former Jedi who
survived order 66. an incident in every
live-action Star Wars season keeps
revisiting to re-traumatize us now
Ahsoka is set around the same time as
the Mandalorian season 3 so order 66
would have been about three decades
prior to this and given baylen's age he
would not have been a young Lane like
grogu or Revo were were the kids that
Anakin ran into Mr Anakin you remember
that poor kid but rather he would have
been an adult Anakin's age who likely
just wasn't around the temple during The
Purge but Balin since then has turned
into a mercenary played by Ray Stevenson
Ray Stevenson sadly passed away this
past May and he looks so good in show
it's just a shame that he's not gonna be
around for all the fan attention he's
gonna get for it Valen's goal has taken
on an apprentice shinhati played by
Ivana sakno in Norse mythology skull is
the name of the wolf that chases the sun
around the sky whereas the wolf hati
chases the moon so I think the naming
there was intentional and later when
Shin assaults the bridge of this new
Republic ship we see that she has a Jedi
Padawan braid and they use not red but
orange lightsabers and Dave Loney
explained to Screen Rant that this was
intentional and that was very
intentional I didn't make them like just
a stark red I remember as a kid that
faders lightsaber kind of fluctuated
from visual effects to visual effects
being a little bit more orange I didn't
want it to go like straight up orange
but it's identifying a little bit of
something maybe to kids that they might
not straight up be what you think they
are in the beginning meanwhile these new
Republic soldiers wear the same blue
uniforms and domed white helmets that
we've seen officers wear in the
Mandalorian behind them and the hangar
are part T70 x-wings from the new
Republic era and it looks like an a-wing
and all these are painted with blue the
rental Alliance blue Squadron was
previously decommissioned after the
battle of scarif in Rogue one but
recently in season 3 of the Mandalorian
Zeb Cameo wearing a Blue flight suit and
in later trailer footage for the show
there has been Iman calamari pilot and
blue standing beside Harrison Doula
since the ghost appeared in the Battle
of scarif in Rogue one presumably Hera
and Zeb were there for that battle the
blue Squadron could live on through them
Balin stabbed his officer with his
lightsaber saying we're no Jedi echoing
ahsoka's dramatic line for Rebels and
her epic duel with Vader I am no Jedi
now at that time it was meant to show
ahsoka's Divergence from the Jedi Order
but for Balin I think it's a sign that
he and Ahsoka may be on a similarly
Rogue path just at this moment
interpreting it from different certain
points of view let's move on
I started hearing whispers
thrawn's return as heir to the Empire
what happens when we find thrawn
power
such as you've never dreamed
[Music]
so we see Ahsoka in some ruins with an
engraving of this hooded female figure
holding an orb could this be the
daughter of mortise the deity from the
realm of mortis in the Clone Wars ARC
who most identified with Ahsoka in
particular part of basically the Holy
Trinity of the Star Wars Universe the
Father the Son and the daughter now the
issue with this is normally the daughter
is not hooded yet would never cover up
that do so this could be some other
figure maybe some ancient Jedi someone
we might meet in the acolyte but this
figure is positioned along a coordinate
line in fact her midsection with the orb
looks like it's on a separate layer that
looks like it might rotate and lock into
place like a Rubik's Cube puzzle a
puzzle that might actually require this
orb to be plugged in for it all to align
it seems like in the show Ahsoka might
be in a race with Balin and shin who I
think are working for thrawn and Morgan
ellsbeth two ruins like this to uncover
an ancient star map a star map pointing
to where well I've speculated bis which
in Legends is the true center of the
Galaxy in Palpatine's Throne world not
that far from Thai python the planet
that grogu communicate with Luke
Skywalker from in the Mandalorian season
2 but if not that many are theorizing
that this may be pointing to a portal to
the world Between Worlds that's from
Rebels season one it's a mystical realm
allowing a kind of time travel that
allowed Ezra to pull Ahsoka from her
duel with the Darth Vader it's crazy and
Dave filoni has described it as an echo
of historical events there's just still
a lot of unknowns and questions about
what exactly the world Between Worlds is
and many are hoping that this Ahsoka
series might dig into it we see balen
and shin shuttle in front of these other
ruins on a Cliffside showing a
Stonehenge s configuration on a circular
base that's been divided into eight
wedges we actually later see Ahsoka
dueling Balin in the setting as it
projects a star map in a hologram behind
their ship in the corners there are some
red leaves this is likely the same
planet that has trees with red leaves
that we see in other shots but the
broken shards of these ruins make me
wonder if these Stones connected at the
top and arches that stretched across the
base at some point was this map
structure destroyed to keep something
hidden valence says that once they find
thrawn they'll gain power
such as you'd never dreamed could that
power be something from the world
Between Worlds like maybe a chance to go
back in time and disrupt the events of
Order 66 and prevent so much pain and
suffering we see Morgan activating the
hollow map from the pedestal in the
center of this place Illuminating lines
with nodes on the inside of these stone
columns and her hand hovers over a mini
Galaxy but a green flame beneath maybe a
knot of the night sister Magic from
dathomir like the green energy mother
Towson used to heal Maul Dave filoni
re-canonized The Witches of daphomir
from that line from Danny Trejo in the
book of Boba Fett and Morgan ellismith
may be one of those witches of dothamir
these ruins are one of two sets of ruins
were seen in trailer footage like these
dark ones on the Cliffside and the
lighter ones set in the black volcanic
Sands at Ahsoka explores with a giant
statues seen more in the previous
trailer could these two sets of ruins be
linked like a Jedi Ruins versus a Sith
ruins or could this be linked to the
mortis one for the daughter one for the
sun both needed to triangulate the path
to the father let's move on
I've spent most of my life fighting a
war
that's why I'm trying to convince you to
help me prevent another one
you and I both know who could help you
with this
she's still just as stubborn as ever
okay we see some of the new Republic
Fleet large round hold Mont calamari
Cruisers and cr90 Corvettes those are
the one with the 11 back thrusters like
the tantan forehead we also see some
ram-headed Hammerhead Corvettes like we
saw in Rogue one and we see a shot of
Harrison Villa piloting the Phantom 2.
this is the sheathaped class transport
they replaced the original auxiliary
Starfighter the Phantom and we see on
the back of Hera's jacket is the ghost
crew logo and we see Chopper helping her
chase down this other transport vessel
that's towing a piece of Machinery
they're over this industrial setting
surrounded by water which I'm pretty
sure is the same exact scrapyard
location where Ahsoka duels The
Inquisitor later looks like they're part
of the same Mission now long time new
Rockstar's viewers know how much we use
geology and how long we've been using it
for but if this is your first time
hearing about geology get ready for
Blockbuster quality skincare on a
student film budget geology is a 23-time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oil-ness prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
for you all you gotta do is take a quick
30 second quiz right now if you use the
code new Rockstar's 100 geology will
give you 100 off their award-winning
skincare trial set you'll also get an
additional bonus offer of up to 30 off
one skin hair or body products when you
add it to your trial it's truly a while
to offer one of the best they've ever
given our audience so click the link in
the description or go to
geolog.i.e rockstars 100 to get started
Harris is the line I spent most of my
life fighting a war that's why I'm
trying to convince you to help me
prevent another one she's pleading with
a group of New Republic Senators
including mon mothma Genevieve O'Reilly
turning from originally playing the
character and that deleted scene from
Revenge of the Sith she doesn't play the
character in Rogue one and most recently
in Andor now she's back in that
senatorial era haircut at her side is
Senator Hamada ziono the senator from
hosnian Prime father to kazuta siono
both characters from Star Wars
resistance this conference is actually
taking place in the same exact kind of
Amphitheater war council room that we
saw in Return of the Jedi when mon
Mothman gave her speech about the
buffins Ahsoka agreets Hera in a hangar
followed by the Droid huyang as Harris
suggests Ahsoka reconnect with Sabine
who now has let her hair grow out we see
ahsoka's T6 shuttle departing the same
lothal communication Tower where we last
saw these two at the end of rebels and
more on them in the next section
I bet your master found you difficult at
times Anakin never got to finish my
training I walked away from him just
like I walked away from Sabine you never
made things easy for me
master
Sabine charges down one of those roads
on the fall that we saw throughout
Rebels on a speeder bike and she's
pursued by an e-wing and it's so cool to
see one of these in Canon because
previously these only showed up in
Legends literature first introduced in
the dark Empire Comic they're known as
escort shuttles that were introduced
during thrawn's campaign to rebuild the
Fallen Empire on sabine's helmet is a
drawing of a loath cat and the oribish
letters Besh imp and Besh nth is an
interesting one it's not commonly seen
in these shows because it's an orbatch
vowel of a plus e so really This spells
out babe because Sabine it's a proud
smoke show Hera tells Ahsoka I bet your
master found you difficult at times
Ahsoka responds Anakin never got to
finish my training I walked away from
him just like I walked away from Sabine
zabin says you never made things easy
for me master and a lot to unpack here
first Ahsoka is acknowledging that she
left Anakin and might carry some guilt
over that and that her training which
piece of in an amazing in Tales of the
Jedi season one episode that training
was really incomplete and had to teach
herself over the years but also it
sounds like after the events of the
rebels finale Ahsoka spent some time
training Sabine I don't think the
implication is that Sabine Wren is force
sensitive because not everyone can be
poor sensitive folks but rather I just
think that Ahsoka trained her in
lightsaber combat similar to how Kanan
trained Sabine with the darksaber and it
looks like there will be one scene where
Ahsoka initially reunites with Sabine on
that same Tower where Sabine refuses to
call followed by a later scene after
Sabine has cut her hair where she gets
back in the action we briefly cease to
be joining Ahsoka on the ship where a
hollow display shows the first ruins
that I talked about with the large
statues that Ahsoka explores at the top
of the first teaser it looks like there
are actually three statues taller than
the rest the top half's broken off could
these be for the Father the Son and the
daughter we see the e-wing flying ahead
of Sabine parking on the road to cut her
off it's being skids beneath that to the
surprise of this interesting Astromech
who released some Sparks of confusion
maybe he's reading babe on her helmet
and going whoa whoa agreed but this
Droid is based on the Vintage R2D2 toy
from Kenner with the teardrop indents
with the red in the blue eyepieces I
love this detail alright next clip
as a Jedi sometimes you have to make the
decision no one else can
but I'm counting on you to see this
through
nice haircut
the trailer slows down for a beat with
these somber strings the Sabine watches
what I assume is a recording of Ezra
Bridger or maybe she actually found the
guy and he prefers to stay long distance
in her room we see Doodles of a loath
wolf and a loath cat there's also a
drawing of a stormtrooper helmet with a
red Ghostbusters line through it and
then in this profile shot we see her
kneeling in front of her Mandalorian
helmet and she cuts her hair
remindedness of Kanan Jairus how he cut
his hair in Rebels as he prepared for a
rescue mission behind her in the back of
the room is a scout trooper helmet which
could have actually belonged to Ezra
Bridger maybe one of the ones that they
wore when they infiltrated the lothal
temple before Ezra crossed into the
world Between Worlds and then there's
almost an exact Recreation of the rebels
finale scene with Ahsoka and Sabine now
with her hair short again in front of
that mural of the ghost Crew looking
exactly like it did in Rebels with the
same exact 2D art that we saw in that
scene so I assume this might actually be
the final scene of episode 1 of the show
but there is a key difference before
Ahsoka wore a light cloak but now it's a
darker gray one Dave filoni is indicated
before that he sees Ahsoka as kind of a
gandal figure and he ended Rebels with
her in lighter clothes to indicate her
return to a more heroic path but seeing
her in Darker robes here is really a
reversal of the Gandalf the Gray to Gand
off the white transition Ahsoka is back
in the shadows which isn't a bad thing
because I think they're convenience she
teams up with other morally compromised
figures like bailin but Shin The
Apprentice might be too far gone a proxy
of what would have happened to Ahsoka if
she followed Anakin off the d-bend
moving on
sometimes we have to do what's right
regardless of our personal feelings
we'll be in vain
in the scrapyard where Imperial Star
Destroyers are being dismantled Ahsoka
is fighting an hk-47 assassin Droid and
an Inquisitor they have the same rotate
and handle lightsaber inquisitors
normally carry now in the past I
wondered if this might be the eighth
brother who only really fell in Rebels
but no skilled jumper would die from
falling like that however that eighth
brother had different feet and this
Inquisitor wears humanoid boots also
they have a more slender build I think
this might be a female it's interesting
because Ahsoka has some connection to
this Inquisitor someone from her past
because we see Ahsoka Julian an
Inquisitor by the darker ruins as well
at the end of the trailer I'm wondering
if this could be Baris offy the Jedi
Apprentice to luminar and Julie who
really staged those bombings of the
temple that Ahsoka was initially blamed
for it could have been Barris offi as an
Inquisitor that allowed the grand
Inquisitor to capture luminar and Dooley
in that Rebels Episode I'm pretty sure
we have not seen the last of bear Safi
in Star Wars fiction and if she's gonna
come back it's gonna be in this show
considering her connection to Ahsoka
okay the next shot the T6 approaches a
massive Pergo whale and she ends up
being sore through the potentials as
they're fired on by someone else maybe
Shin we saw these Pergo from a distance
from grogu's eyes as he and ninja and
flew through hyperspace in the
Mandalorian season 3 premiere but up
close like this they are way larger than
they were in Rebels could this be the
alpha Pergo or the ones that took Ezra
and thrawn just babies speaking of
thrawn we finally get our first official
look at Lars Mickelson since Star Wars
celebration last year Gran Admiral
thrawn red chiss eyes and dark blue skin
now if you want to know more about
thrawn I broke down his full history
both his publication history and its new
canonical history he's brilliant he's
murderous not a good guy not someone we
should admire but he's still exactly the
villain Star Wars is so desperately
needed and I'm so excited for him all
right moving on you have no power
Anakin spoke highly of you
I'm not here to discuss my past okay
Shannon Sabine at duel on this planet
with the dark ruins based off of the
trees in the background Shen has her
orange blade Sabine uses the Ezra
bridger's old lightsaber with its green
blade but many believe that Shin might
be using Kanan jairus's old lightsaber
which would need to be recovered from
when it fell off the Imperial Dome on
the fall right before his death but we
know from the Obi-Wan Kenobi series that
inquisitors keep recovered Jedi
lightsabers as trophies in the fortress
inquisitorious on nerve so maybe the
reason that kyber Crystal only produces
an orange color is that some essence of
Kane and jarretts could live on inside
of it and it's destined to get back to
Harrison Doula and her and kanan's son
Jason balen taught Ahsoka by telling her
that Anakin spoke highly ever telling us
that the two Jedi knew each other so
during the Clone Wars years there were
probably several trials and Adventures
and team-ups and we never saw that
Anakin might have had Aidan Christensen
is going to return in the series I'm
wondering if it's gonna be a flashback
with Balon as a two former Jedi compare
notes on their apprentices then we see
Ahsoka running after her T6 as the ruins
we saw her in in the last trailer now
explode behind her where they bombed was
it a trap no I don't think this was an
artificial explosion because look at
those debris smoke Trails the black
volcanic sand Ahsoka is running across I
think these ruins were built into a
dormant volcano that's now erupting okay
on to the last clip we have a lot of
work to do once a rebel always a rebel
foreign
the same Droid from the Jedi ship The
Crucible who starts with teaching young
Jedi he's voiced by David Tennant in the
series which has got to be a nod to his
role as Doctor Who because now he's
Professor who different spelling then a
really weird shot the Ada Class Shuttle
is firing both on Ahsoka and The
Inquisitor she was fighting in the
scrapyard it's hard to tell the shuttle
could be firing Behind The Inquisitor
and only had Ahsoka but it looks like
both are in the blast range and they're
both running toward the shuttle which is
also weird for the final shot ahsoka's
duel with that Inquisitor as she
patiently waits for the helicopter twirl
and then lunges forward to jam the
propeller with his powerful thrust this
downward ankle position is also ahsoka's
pose in the official poster for the
series and it was one of Anakin's
favorite positions and I don't think
that's a coincidence I'm so excited for
this series we will be breaking down
each episode starting August 23rd here
on the new Rockstar's main Channel with
our Wikileaks reactions on the break
room Channel subscribe to all three
channels on our Network and support us
by grabbing some merch at nerdright.shop
follow me on all social media at eavos
following the rockstars And subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
AI